holiday season is being dampened by the
coronavirus pandemic again this year
especially if you're planning to travel
by air more than 700 u.s flights are
already canceled today and that's on top
of hundreds that were called off on
christmas eve airlines say they're being
hit with staff shortages due to the
rapidly spreading omicron variant the
first known case of omicron in the u.s
was reported on december 1st the variant
is now the dominant strain of the
coronavirus accounting for about 73
percent of all cases in this country and
it spread quickly the average number of
new cases is up 45 percent in the past
week and it's more than double what it
was on december first the good news for
now is that despite the surge in cases
new hospitalizations have stayed mostly
flat nationwide but the holiday travel
woes are the latest reminder of just how
disruptive the pandemic has become
at airports across the country flight
cancellations were mostly due to airline
staff calling out sick or reporting
they'd been exposed to the virus there's
just so much that
any employer can do
for those that work in offices employers
can say stay home and work remotely
but that's not the case with airline
personnel earlier this week delta asked
the cdc to shorten isolation times for
vaccinated airline workers who test
positive from 10 days to 5. at the same
time air travel was projected to spike
184 percent this year over 2020 with 30
million passing through tsa checkpoints
now that it's been more than a year
since vaccinations became available
we're at much lower risk this christmas
than we were last christmas but we still
must hang our stockings with care dr
william shafer is an infectious disease
specialist offering advice for the
holidays
and i hope we're all gathering
vaccinated and boosted
and then in addition before we all
gather many of us are getting a rapid
test on christmas day to make sure that
we're all negative then we can
share the joy
in a much more relaxed fashion but with
so many not able to take off there was
more frustration than relaxing the
machine's not working right
it's just terrible it's awful it's awful
nice siblings and my parents i think
they're a little bit stressed out right
now trying to figure it out even as many
prepared to travel by getting tested i
think if they've been tested before
they've gotten on the plane
then i think you're in really pretty
good shape but as predicted omicron
spreads fast new york reported nearly 45
000 new cases friday a 14 jump from the
day before breaking records for the
seventh time in just over a week in los
angeles the number of daily cases
tripled in three days to nearly ten
thousand in many places testing is free
but what about holiday get-togethers for
people who aren't tested let's all
gather together wear the mask
keep social distancing except during the
time when we're eating and religious
services in many places are taking extra
precautions with more churches offering
online services this year we are having
the masks available and we are
distancing so that we can make sure that
christmas is not only merry but is safe